now the world health organization has
declared the fast-spreading monkey pox
outbreak a global health emergency it's
the who's highest level of alert it was
issued by the un health agency chief
despite a deadlock among experts over
the decision
thinks the risk of the virus is high in
europe and moderate globally more than
70 nations are now experiencing an
outbreak of the virus which is common in
parts of central and west africa
we have an outbreak that has spread
around the world rapidly through new
models of transmission about which we
understand too little
and which meets the criteria in the
international health regulations
for all of these reasons
i have decided that the global monkey
box outbreak represents a public health
emergency of international concern
lawrence uh gosten is the director of
the wh so center on global health law
he's also the founding o'neill chair in
the global health law at georgetown
university and he joins us live from
washington dc thanks very much indeed
for being on the program so just how
worried should we be about monkey pox
now
well i mean we should absolutely be
worried um
we've seen an exponential rise in monkey
pox cases it's now
in all in five wh
regions of the world
in
many many dozens of countries
with cases rising exponentially
so it's of concern right now
um outside of uh endemic areas in in
central and east africa
it's primarily but not exclusively but
primarily
within
communities of men who have sex with men
but that should not lead to complacency
that that community
matters a lot
and it also could spill over easily to
other communities as we've seen with the
hiv epidemic and give us an idea then
what are the symptoms what should people
be watching out for if they're watching
this now
well you know there there are
characteristic monkey pox um rashes um
that they should be looking at
um particularly if they're in a an
elevated risk group that if they've had
um uh intimate sexual relationships or
close physical contact with somebody who
might be ill
there should be contact tracing
there should be widespread testing and
there should be
a
strategic deployment of
vaccines to really try to nip this in
the bud but the window for containment
of monkey pox is
rapidly closing and you know we we fear
um that this could become endemic
in europe north america and other parts
of the world
over the next months and years given
what you say then why do you think it's
appearing in regions where it hasn't
done so
before
well that's exactly what dr tedros the
director general is is pointing out
we we've never before had
um such widespread outbreaks of cases
that are not travel related
to africa
clearly there are
new or different modes of transmission
clearly it's gotten a foothold
particularly in europe and north america
but there's no reason why it should not
spread more widely
outside of those regions
just as we've seen with other sexually
transmitted infections like
hiv we've really got to take this
seriously and i do applaud
um dr tedros for declaring an emergency
it was politically brave in fact
it's the first time in history a
director general has declared an
emergency without a clear recommendation
from the emergency committee of the
world health organization so he's done a
politically courageous thing and we all
need to thank him because it's better to
err
on the side of action than in action
well in fact we we understand that he
was something of a tiebreaker on the who
committee to make this declaration so it
was a close call then
it was
you know you remember it was only a few
weeks ago
that dr tejo said
convene the emergency committee and they
decided
you know by a significant majority not
to declare an emergency i always thought
that was wrong i thought that they
should have
the international health regulations
criteria were clearly met
um when tajos
re-convened the committee i think he was
sending
a signal to the committee that he was
really worried
this time it was much closer although
the majority of the committee a slight
majority
voted against the emergency
but tejos
decided and he was legally entitled to
do that
but this was an emergency and declared
it such and i'm really um delighted to
see the kind of courageous leadership
he's shown here
okay we'll leave it there lawrence
augustine we very much appreciate your
time here on al jazeera thank you